which leads us now to the final show
that I guess we force ourselves to watch
the goat if you will the goats the
classic I think the MILF Manor was worse
than this okay I think so for me yeah
this one I get the most so
so Euphoria is one of the most like
Infamous anime that has uh oh I should
say hentai that has been released visual
novel first yeah it was a visual novel
first and I remember like watching this
like this was this was that one anime
that everyone recommended to you if you
were like on in like
online back in like 2000 like the mid
2000s it started with Boku no Pica yeah
and after that craze died down craze
died down yeah everyone was like all
right we got to find another one to to
troll the unexpected with yeah and then
some genius was like I saw I found this
show called Euphoria yeah still one of
my one of my favorite Twitter threads to
this day is uh the first time that
Sydney discovered Euphoria this was back
before she did YouTube this was back
before she was the queen of degeneracy I
remember one day she was just uh she we
were in Sydney's we were into his room
and she was like have you had this thing
called Euphoria and I was like yeah
why'd you ask and she was like people
keep recommending it to me why do people
keep recommending it to me and I was
like oh it looks uh it's a pretty
Infamous anime and uh it's a pretty
Infamous game as well and she goes oh
why is it Infamous and I was like don't
worry about it honey yeah and then so
what I what she and then she decides of
like curiosity oh just download the
vision of them played the visual novel
and I'm just like you should uh you
should uh tweet your live thoughts on
that honey let's let's see let's see
what you think yeah she played the
visual yeah like 30 hours long it's
longer than that yeah I've played it as
well yeah it's like played it yeah it's
like I got curious man okay I have a
question okay
this is supposed to make sense from the
anime alone no because I I swear bro I
tried and I don't know what was
happening I've watched this so many
times more than yeah
no yeah no it doesn't it it's not
supposed to make I'm not done like it's
not supposed to make sense I guess in
the Creator's Minds it's supposed to
make sense but like I played the visual
novel I've seen the hentai more times
than I'm proud to say and I'm just like
still don't get it yeah I understood
serial experiments Lane better so I
managed to figure out uh in the second
episode that I was kind of watching
different endings kind of different
different routes it was like but it was
like it was like The Abridged version of
the routes and then the ending that kind
of yes it was weird because it was like
I was like man I feel like we're just
going through the motions and it's also
not clear what's happening technically
speaking it's like the first four
episodes are the different routes you
can go on with like the different girls
and then episode five is the bad end and
episode six which is the final episode
is the true I thought it was the other
way around I I thought it was the other
one
I thought every episode had the good end
for each girl yeah uh and sometimes the
bad I don't know it's it's like to be
honest I don't remember yeah so so to
explain the basic premise of this yeah I
actually should do that yeah we should
do that before we get into like
um theories
a Euphoria Theory thanks for watching
thanks for jacking so uh it's very very
similar to I guess any kind of like
death game or saw or that kind of
premise okay it's hentai squid games
I saw his hentai saw it is it is more
deranged so yeah so what happens is this
guy wakes up in a completely white room
with I think like four or six guys
six originally okay and then one of them
refuses to participate oh that's right
with six girls and uh he basically has
to uh get out of this room by performing
various acts to a girl of his choosing
and obviously some of these acts can uh
range from I was gonna say pretty
vanilla stuff uh yeah pretty like
comparatively light stuff like oh just
uh put on a sexy like BDSM outfit and go
hard uh and some uh like uh I just saw
Contraptions some just saw Contraptions
like oh just be a human toilet and I'm
not going to explain what that is but uh
yeah they're already glossed over that
in the [__] shirt that's episode
thankfully yeah
um and if they don't do it then they die
so yeah so they have a they all have
these collars I guess mind control yeah
which mind control and also I guess if I
remember correctly like if they don't do
what the the the master you know the the
game master says then like I think they
explode or they like cut your head off
or something it's something like that
basically yeah they have this thing
that's attached to the neck that they
can't get rid of so they're basically at
the will of the game master yeah so so
before we get into too deeply into this
how many episodes did you watch of
euphoria I I sat down and actually
watched fully uh one or six but I
skimmed through all of them so like I I
sat there and I was like okay all right
get it get it all right all right so I
kind of watched most of it I mean you
didn't watch episode five which I did
watch episode five and I was very
confused yeah okay episode five is
actually like I watch you know because I
I actually ended up re-watching all of
it because I was I watched episode I
watched episode one and I'm like I need
to refresh myself I watched episode five
and I was like am I just like has it
just been a super long time since I
watched this maybe I just need to watch
the previous episodes for context I
ended up watching every episode I was
like that didn't help at all no like
holy [__] episode five I think is the
end of Ava for [__] for henta like
this this [__] made no sense this [__]
made no sense yeah and it was like in
one episode certain characters would be
evil and good yeah and the next episode
they would Swap and I was like why can
we explain these things and it was just
bad yeah it was just [__] like I I don't
even think it was like as gross as some
other stuff like I think I think the the
maid Mansion one was grosser for me it
was but I think the one thing that to
this day no matter how many times I
watched it that just pisses me off about
Euphoria is that God damn it's so well
animated yeah well the first episode and
the second episode okay no then it went
off a cliff no they were all well landed
I thought it was worse animation at the
end I I thought it was pretty pretty
good it's a pretty consistent episode
three a damn good animation I think his
his the [__] up thing right his his
the [__] up thing
um obviously the um the premise is
[__] up and everything of course okay
there are some scenes that is just uh
not safe for life I will not touch with
a 10-foot barge Pro uh the worst thing
about Euphoria is that every so often
they'll sprinkle in what I think is a
actually pretty good scene like what
give me an example Give an example like
what like yeah it's an example there was
there is a scene at the end of like
episode three whereas like the main guy
and the girl with like yeah
um the emotionless girl right oh yes
yeah and they and then and they just
have like I would say a pretty pretty
vanilla sex scene is that the one in the
bed right with the bedroom yeah and I'm
like damn she she goes from being oh no
it's not the Western one it's the other
one it's the long-haired girl like yeah
yeah and then she gets like pregnant and
[__]
we'll get to that we'll we'll get to
that no no this is this was before I
found out the plot twist of who this
girl was like all I'm all I'm saying oh
I just realized who she was yeah because
I connected the dots to what they said
in the last episode yeah she's a goal in
episode three yeah
yeah
wait that's like how many years apart is
that then
okay that's just the theory
wait sir how many years are they trapped
in this [__] sex game I don't know
like 10 [__] years I don't think it's
ever stated yeah it's it's never stated
what what I don't get is that like this
dude is the embodiment of like there are
two wolves inside of me and except
except both the Wolves want to do our
word to people yes this is this dude is
literally Ken kaneki if he was a hentai
protagonist you know it's like it was so
confusing all the time figuring out what
was real and what wasn't yeah because it
would be like this is real no this
wasn't this was real none of this as
well they tried to do like a millennium
actress thing where it's just like you
don't know if it's real or not yeah it
was so [__] it was [__] I I don't even
like it's just boring it was boring as
well
I actually thought there was I wouldn't
say it's boring I wouldn't say I thought
there were some scenes I thought was
pretty I okay I I really liked nemu I
don't know why uh the first episode
first the first episode girl uh yeah but
I mean isn't she in all of them
she's not the main focus of all right
right in the first episode yeah yeah I
it's it's episode one in episode five
she's like the main yeah I guess yeah
yeah I remember first time watching
Euphoria I'm like man she has a
shit-eating grin and I was like oh oh oh
okay
I was not prepared for yeah when I saw
that I was like God
yeah so episode five they do like what I
can only describe as human centipede oh
this Euphoria did Human Centipede like
years before Human Centipede became like
a meme yeah
I definitely skipped over that yeah
because I remember I think I saw his
glimpse of it I was like nope yeah um
I'm gonna watch this yeah yeah so like I
don't know why
the story became so confusing
um but the basic premise is every in
every episode there's a different girl
with a different who I'm guessing they
follow a different roots and some and so
and sometimes you get a happy ending and
sometimes you get a glimpse of the Bad
Endings as well but then they decide to
put both in one episode and that's that
was what was confusing too yeah it's
really [__] confusing yeah yeah all
of it yeah because then in episode six
they bring out this like cold sex cult
that comes out of nowhere yeah you're
like actually above ground is where we
have the cult and below ground is where
you guys are yeah
see I I thought I thought being a fate
fan I can I can keep track of convoluted
timelines and I watch Euphoria and I'm
like oh I know nothing did this only get
like popular because of the centipede
thing
no it got popular I think because it
because I think like when you look at
just the surface of it the art is really
nice the character designs are really
nice yeah the the premise is like I
think when Euphoria came out there was
very few hentai that had a premise as
just openly as [__] up as that right
okay one thing one thing I'll say
because a lot of the hentai we watched
today are for this episode they were
like 15 minutes long yeah and I was like
watching re-watching all of euphoria I
was like God damn I miss when hentai
were won half an hour in length and two
or like more than two episodes yeah
re-watching all of euphoria after all
the other ones we watched was like
watching the [__] Lord of the Rings
yeah I'm like God damn this is long too
long it was way too long the hours of
the show Jesus 10 minutes in I was like
God
so two and a half hours of this [__]
wow did you not even like the teacher at
all the little the teacher was are you
[__] you knew I was gonna
uh appealing to me but yeah
you know I I just didn't I don't know he
didn't deserve it yeah well I don't know
man I don't know about that
what do you mean he didn't deserve it as
in like he didn't deserve any any able
to do anything he should have just died
like right away well would have a lot
shorter it would have been the story at
all uh yeah it would have been good it
would have been ended maybe he'd been
like you know what I expect these women
I'm not gonna do that yeah and then they
just all died and it's like cool yeah
better than what happened so what I what
I think was like the weirdest plot twist
was actually in episode six where we go
to the sex course because we had like
the human centipede thing and obviously
that's [__] up
um I don't know what is they decided to
put that in but obviously like I believe
the human centipede was made as a
concept because they were thinking about
how best to punish like sexual predators
or something like that right so the fact
that someone in Japan made this to think
that people would jack off to this that
disturbs me more yeah yeah that disturbs
me more uh and then in in episode six we
find out that one of the girls who he
has been one of the girls who he's been
having sex with
um the one in episode three
turns out that she's the daughter of
um the leader of this sex cult who uh
who the main guy impregnated years ago
so essentially this girl is just his
daughter yeah yeah this guy this girl is
just his daughter and now that I
realized that literally just like five
minutes ago it's so nasty
and it's and it's extra disturbing to
think that episode three which involves
the daughter is probably the most
wholesome episode in the entire series
it is probably the most wholesome
episode and the one where you get the
most vanilla sex yeah and you're just
like oh wait oh oh no oh God but then it
also confused me when I found out about
that plot and I was thinking back to
episode three and like all the other
previous episodes
it literally makes no sense
chronologically yeah like it's not
possible like did he [__] her in a
hyperbolic Time Chamber like what yeah
like that's the only explanation maybe
they're in a world where like boys stop
puberty at age one I don't I don't
understand how this is like it doesn't
make [__] sense and I'm glad it
doesn't because it's [__] stupid see
what what I was thinking his his mind
stop doing the math I was like it
doesn't matter his here's my theory okay
here's my theory because there's this
really weird they do a [__] Marvel
post-credits scene in episode two which
is I don't know I don't know why yeah
probably because you skipped it they did
this really weird thing and uh at the
end of episode two where nemu comes in
dressed like a scientist and one of the
girls in like a virtual reality like got
a got a VR headset right and it kind of
frames the entire thing as like an
experiment right so I don't maybe all
this thing is just happening in his mind
maybe all this thing is a VR experiment
does that make it less [__] off or is
it still [__] up
because they're still animated okay it's
it's still [__] up because you know
what you know why because like they give
they frame episode six they frame the
entire episode as a good ending yeah
which is awesome ending and you know
what the [__] good ending is
he has two children with his daughter
that is the good ending yeah that is the
vanilla ending that is that is the
vanilla ending of euphoria
um and I yeah I don't know if that's if
that's vanilla what the hell is the bad
ending is what I found like a like a
like a hentai plot written by a four
Channel and it somehow just got like
approved like that's what it felt like
like it felt like a just a like a rookie
I don't know maybe it's good because
when I was looking on YouTube I was like
I need someone to explain this somebody
had like a 45 minute video being like
why euphora is actually a masterpiece
yeah like it wasn't I was like [__] off
it wasn't I didn't even count it as like
the good ending it's just the Lesser bad
Indie yeah right or I guess the true
ending I don't know I'll say the episode
that pissed me off the most episode five
which you kind of see yeah yeah well I
saw the ending yeah and I was like what
yeah so episode the episode five genuine
this is why it's the end like this is
why it's the end of April of like hand
Cycles this dude is literally Shinji
okay this dude is literally Shinji so
what happens is like in episode five
they reveal I guess who the main
Mastermind of the games are yeah and so
she comes out she reveals herself and
she's like because they escape yeah
because they somehow one of the tiles is
loose and there's an underground tunnel
again yeah yeah and then she reveals
herself she reveals herself and she
she's like I'll give you the option you
either kill me or kill nemu who is the
main girl of that show yeah or all of
the other girls die and I'm gonna
continue killing people until you choose
to either kill me or kill that girl yeah
and he's like I don't want to ride and
it's the childhood friend right yeah
yeah the child main character it's the
child
in episode two yeah you could either
kill a murderer or somebody who's not a
murderer yeah
it was literally just the [__] Shinji
get in the robot moment of just like
just do it oh my [__] do it the
choice is so obvious no matter who you
ask yeah and he just happens to be the
worst Choice he makes the worst choice
of doing nothing and the war happens is
that she proceeds to take out his three
of the other girls and he just they she
just decapitates them yeah in front of
them and then he's still like yeah I'm
not gonna do it no I'm not gonna do it
you're still my childhood friend we've
been good friends this is not the girl
you are I know
and then they proceed to do the human
centipede thing yeah the worst part is
he [__] ejaculates during the human
centipede moment that was a mister that
was that was the moment that I had
blacked out for my memory and then and
then and then after that he the girl
drugs the main guy and Nemo yeah with
some kind of like sex crazed drug or
something yeah and and then at the end
of it all
he just snaps her neck mid-sex and I'm
like
every every option you have done this
entire way has just gotten worse and
worse and worse there was one thing I
was confused by where like I think she
shot nemu with an imaginary gun or
something and she just dies oh yeah oh
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're trying to escape yeah she pulls
out a gun like a finger gun they're like
haha then it cuts to another shot of her
holding a gun you're like wait what
that's why I was like this is some
virtual reality [__] going on man I'm
waiting for like I was waiting for like
that big plot twist drop and then it
just never happened no they gave us the
plot twist drop but they all but they
just didn't explain the twist yeah I I
think the reason why this got so popular
is because back in the day
um this was just at the time one of the
most messed up hentai that was available
and also really one thing is that you
know we we are [__] on the story but
they actually had a they they put a lot
of thought into this story they were
[__] didn't go in the right place it was
[__] but the effort was there the
execution was not I remember do you know
do you know my first experience for
Euphoria it wasn't even like I didn't
start with episode one uh it was
actually episode three right and I
remember I remember like looking at the
art style I was like oh this looks this
looks pretty good all right all right
let's let's see what this is about look
clicks epic like clicks uh clicks an
episode of this uh this video which
turns out to be episode of episode three
of euphoria I got click baited by the
[__] thumbnail I was like oh okay
let's see what this is about the first
scene is a girl getting decapitated and
I have never I my penis has never gone
flaccid so fast holy [__] dude you just
got LimeWire yeah I did I did
not hand sections
and that was my very first experience
with Euphoria so like that was like I
said after that I was like you know I
wasn't even in the mood anymore but I
needed to Google what the [__] this was
yeah that's that's how I discovered and
still talked about to this day and it's
it is still talked about to this day as
uh one of the most infamous uh one of
the most infamous visual novels and
Anime to be made the thing I will say is
that I feel like now
the visual novel was still like way
worse yeah so I feel like they glossed
over some of the most messed up scenes
from the visual novel like the like the
human toilet because there are multiple
human toilets yeah I'm gonna skip this
don't bother yeah don't um this is the
one time where I'm jealous you don't
like visual novels yeah I'm like you
know what if I if I hit it just
I really would have even get this visual
novel like I assume steam isn't selling
it
it's like yo that was an 80 off on
Euphoria is not like readily available
how did you even get this oh it's
legally available what yeah I think uh I
think Sydney owns an official copy and I
think you can download it legally as
well if you're uh if you're interested
just watch uh see these videos
oh my God there's there's a there's a
lot of websites that sell like even
really really old uh like error games
and visual novels that are properly
licensed by the creators but it's all
just like digitally
um that's how I got my hands on most of
them so yeah I paid for mine and that's
what I got so yeah did you know what
I've realized after watching all of
these hentai I can't drag off anymore
apart from that yes what I just like I
want I want an actual protagonist that
is like interesting for [__] sake
every protagonist that in this in these
hentai's are like the biggest betas of
all time the biggest hurts like Johnny
Sins just star on one of these hentai
yeah yeah I I want a Chad who is likable
yeah you know enough yeah because every
chat in hentai is just the most
detestable human yeah the antiago yeah
like the only hentai I can think of that
I mean I I don't know if I'd call him a
Chad but at least he's like at least
mildly Charming is rants oh yeah Rance
is the closest we'll get to a
protagonist where I'm like yeah you know
what he's an ass he's still an [__]
but you know what God damn you're a
lovable artist yeah yeah